اندلع الذعر في مباراة كرة سلة في
تكساس يوم الأحد بعد أن قال أحدهم إنه
سمع إطلاق نار ، لكن لحسن الحظ تبين أنه
إنذار كاذب ، لكن ها هي الفوضى
التي أعقبت ذلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تعال إلى هنا تعال إلى هنا
ماذا حدث مطلق النار النشط
ما حدث  إلى الباب الخلفي ، اذهب
[موسيقى] ،
هيا ، استيقظ ، تعال ، تعال ، تعال ، هيا ،
هيا ،
هذه
[موسيقى] ،
وقع الحادث بعد أن طُلب من أحد الوالدين
والمدرب الخصم مغادرة
اللعبة  قام أحدهم بإخراج مسدس من
سيارته في ساحة انتظار السيارات ، وقد قررت الشرطة منذ ذلك الحين
أنه لم يتم إطلاق أي طلقات
ولم يصب أحد ، ما يبدو وكأنه
طلقة نارية في الفيديو هو في الواقع رجل
ينطلق فوق طاولة محاولًا الهرب
وهذا الأمر لا يزال قائمًا.  قيد
التحقيق ، هل يقول الكثير أن
ردهم التلقائي على سماع ذلك
الانفجار كان أنه كان مطلق النار نشطًا
جيدًا أعتقد أن هذا طبيعي فقط بالنظر إلى
عدد المرات التي نبلغ عنها فيها عدد
المرات التي يشاهدها الجميع في أمريكا
في الأخبار المحلية والوطنية